sexiest man alive apparently I heard
before because had the little um secret
slip of it Emily Blunt spilling secrets
on former co-star Chris Evans being
named People's sexiest man alive the
actress was working with Evans on their
upcoming flick paint Hustlers when he
found out about his new title I had the
little um secret slip of it but uh I
think he was a bit embarrassed but sort
of secretly thrilled you know who
wouldn't be thrilled sure Chris can take
the title this year but next year the
actress is vying for her hubby John
Krasinski to take the crown own it with
wallpaper all over our house
meanwhile Emily's gearing up for the
release of her latest project the
English
both about to get killed and yet here we
are
well I just thought it was heart
stopping it was so beautiful and
extraordinary writing which is rare and
so when you come across it you just sort
of cling to it and I'd never done a
western
I love the Western genre I grew up
watching westerns I just thought it was
as violent as it was witty and it had
this Tender Love Story at its heart and
I fell in love not only is she the star
of the miniseries Emily also took on the
role of executive producer for the first
time I just really enjoyed every facet
of bringing this thing to life it felt
like a very natural fit for me on this
one because it kind of captured my heart
so deeply so I'm interested in all of it
now I love the acting I love it of
course of course but I want to yeah but
I want to do all of it now you know
foreign